the first  members of the public  come into westminster hall  so  and alistair for so many people this  will be a special experience  when you come to the top of the steps  on entering westminster hall it is a  breathtaking  space and it is like any great stone  hall it is broadly grey  and yet with the  the color of the  royal regalia  the royal standard  and those who form part of the king's  bodyguards and obviously the king's  household division  it's a sparkle of light at the center of  it and so it's very easy for those who  come in to be quite struck  by what they have come upon  and whatever they are thinking on their  way in as they walk down those stairs  and file past and present whatever  token of condolence in their respect  they choose  it really is a building that says  the history of the nation